[Music]
Michelle from lab math and beauty
science here and today we're going to be
talking about more skincare myths if you
follow me at lab muff and beauty science
on instagram you know that I regularly
bust beauty myths earlier I did a video
on five of the biggest skincare myths
and today I'm going to be talking about
five more if you believe in some of
these myths don't feel too bad
I definitely believed in all of these at
some point the important thing is once
we find out that it's a myth we stop
repeating it and we stop perpetuating it
the problem with myths is that they lead
us to act in ways that we think are
beneficial but actually aren't they
might do nothing or they might even be
actively harmful if you like watching
this sort of video I've really
appreciate it if you subscribe to my
youtube channel you can also click the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos and click the like under this
video as well the first myth is that you
should only use chemical exfoliants at
night this myth is about chemical
exfoliants and in particular it's about
the alpha hydroxy acid exfoliant
glycolic acid there were some studies
that found that using glycolic acid
could make your skin photosensitive in
other words it was more sensitive to the
Sun it was easier to get sunburned
I think this myth came because a lot of
people saw the results of this study and
assumed that it was because the glycolic
acid and the skin when sunlight was
shining on it it caused it to react in a
way that it normally wouldn't sort of
like how citrus oils can do this but the
structure of glycolic acid means that it
can't interact with the Sun very
strongly and if you look at what
actually happened in the study it's
pretty clear that this is a myth in the
study 10% glycolic acid and 2% salicylic
acid was applied to volunteers skin for
three and a half weeks then the next day
after the three and a half weeks they
tested the skin with UV and they found
that the area with 10% glycolic acid was
more sensitive so in the study there
wasn't actually fresh glycolic acid on
the skin when it was tested with UV that
means that it's more likely that the
glycolic acid cause the skin to change
in a way that made a more susceptible to
UV damage so for example the cells of
laughter and so light gets through more
easily or there might be less pigment an
interesting part of the study is that
the area that was treated with salicylic
acid did naturally get more
photosensitive and in studies where
salicylic acid was freshly applied on
the skin and then treated with UV they
actually found that salicylic acid was
protective you can see that from the
structure of salicylic acid it can
actually absorb UV salicylic acid also
has anti-inflammatory properties which
could cool down sunburn what you should
be doing instead just use chemical
exfoliants wherever they fit into your
routine if you're using glycolic acid or
any other alpha hydroxy acids make sure
you wear sunscreen as well you should be
wearing sunscreen anyway because it's
really good for your skin if you want to
find out more about how to exfoliate
then I have a free exfoliation guide
that you can download I've got the link
in the description myth number two the
difference between physical and chemical
sunscreens is that physical sunscreens
scatter and reflect UV light while
chemical sunscreens absorb UV light and
converted to heat I see this myth around
a lot from dermatologists and
peer-reviewed articles and other sources
that you would normally expect to be
quite reliable in reality the physical
sunscreens which usually refers to zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide
they only scatter and reflect about 5%
of the sun's UV the other 95% is
absorbed and converted to heat
just like with chemical sunscreens this
might seem like a nitpicky technical
detail that we shouldn't really worry
too much about but the problem is it
does lead to people peaking physical
sunscreens for reasons that aren't
actually true for example some people
think that this is the reason why
chemical sunscreens feel hotter on their
face or that the heat produced by
chemical sunscreens can make melasma
worse when in reality there's only
really a five percent difference so
because of this myth some people turn to
physical sunscreens and then they run
into the biggest drawbacks of these
which is the fact that they're really
thick they tend to be quite
uncomfortable and they often give a
white cast which is where when you apply
it on darker skin not even that dark so
I see this on my skin and then to get
around these problems people apply less
sunscreen which is definitely bad for
you you can find out more about how to
pick and use
degrees in my ebooks the lab muffin guy
basic skincare there is a free sample
chapter which includes lots of
information on sunscreens I've also done
lots and lots of videos about sunscreens
I've linked all of this again in the
description the next myth is that if a
product contains comedogenic ingredients
it will break you out I've done a video
before on the whole concept of chromatid
Nyssa tea but in short the test for
these don't reflect how products are
used in real life firstly the tests were
done on rabbit ears which are not human
faces and there was one very important
false positive very early on which was
petrolatum or petroleum jelly this quad
rapid is but later on they found out
that on human skin it doesn't clog pores
at all newer tests use human skin but
they usually use back skin and they
cover the ingredient with a patch which
is again not how we would use this
product on our skin
the third big issue is that they usually
use a hundred percent of an ingredient
in a product we have dilution
ingredients will interact with each
other and your skin differently if
they've been diluted for example if you
have pure butter versus butter and a
cake it's a very different experience
so these Komoda Janissa tea ratings
might point you in the right direction
if you're trying to work out which
product is breaking you out especially
if it's a product that only has one
ingredient or if it has a really
comedogenic ingredient as one of the top
ingredients even then different people
will react differently to the same
product instead what you should do is
keep track of products that have broken
you out and see if you can work out
which ingredients are common between
them definitely don't throw out products
that have worked for you just based on
these ratings you should also add one
product at a time to your routine so
that you can easily work out which
product is causing you to break out the
next myth is that medical grade skincare
is better for your skin
so firstly to clarify medical-grade
refers to products or brands that are
only sold in dermatology clinics or in
aesthetics clinics they're also
sometimes called clinical products or
professional-grade products this is very
different from prescription medications
like tretinoin cream or over-the-counter
medications like benzoyl peroxide or
sunscreen there are lots of myths about
why medical-grade skin care products are
supposed to look better for example
there's a myth that they're regulated
differently from regular cosmetics which
is not true so-called medical grade
products like cleansers and moisturizers
are not regulated differently from
normal brands that you would get in a
supermarket it is just a marketing term
with no legal meaning there's also the
myth that they automatically contain
higher quality ingredients that they're
rigorously tested that they have
clinical studies to back them up again
this might be true for some brands but
not necessarily just from the term
medical grade it really depends on what
that specific brand wants to do with
their development process even though
the term implies that there's all this
rigorous testing a brand can simply just
slap the term medical grade on their
product and sell it only through
particular clinics and without any of
this testing that would be perfectly
fine there's also the fact that lots of
drugstore products are rigorously tested
especially with the brands that are more
dermatological there's also this myth
that medical grade products are allowed
to penetrate more deeply or contain high
concentrations of actives than so-called
over-the-counter or regular drugstore
products and again it's not true they
aren't regulated differently instead
what you should do is use skincare
products that work for your skin and
your budget and your preferences if a
brand has started to back up their
products that's fantastic look at that
but don't just look at the word medical
grade and expect that that will work
better the final myth is that oily skin
doesn't require moisturizer
I've talked about this myth before in my
video on dry and dehydrated skin oily
skin can produce lots of oil but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's good
at holding on to water so for example my
skin the oil that sits on top of your
skin the sebum isn't actually that good
at holding on to water or preventing
trans epidermal water loss moisturizers
are designed to help your skin and
compensate for lack of oil or lack of
water and there are three main types of
ingredients in these they are occlusives
which sit on top of your skin and trap
water in there are emollients which help
to soften your skin and there are
humectants which hold onto water and
keep it on your skin not all of these
ingredients are oils often occlusives
and emollients aren't loyals but
humectants are not oily so if your skin
is oily you shouldn't just avoid
moisturizers instead what you should do
is check if your skin is dehydration
prone then pick a moisturizer that
addresses that problem if you want a ton
of detail about picking moisturizers you
can check out my video on dry and
dehydrated skin I also have a whole
chapter in my ebook that's all about
picking moisturizers so did you believe
any of these 5 myths I definitely did
are there other myths that you keep
seeing pop up time and time again if so
leave them in the comments and I will
bust them if you like myth-busting you
might want to follow me at lab muffin
beauty science on Instagram where I bust
myths all the time you can of course
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
check out my blogger as well see you
next time